من القاهره معنا مراسلات صباح العربيه سمر
باشات وحديثنا اليوم عن سينما الصيف في
مصر صباح الخير يا سمر
شو القصه صباح الخير يا راويه وصباح الخير
عليكم جميعا يعادل
احنا يعني لا لا ما نسيتكش ما اقدرش صباح
الخير عليكم انتم الاثنين صباح الخير على
كل مشاهدي صباح العربيه في كل مكان صباح
الفل احنا ايام
وهتبتدي تنزل تطرح افلام عيد الاضحى لها
افلام الصيف يعني هيبدا بعيد الاضحى بعد
تقريبا انتهاء الامتحانات في معظم المراحل
يمكن اهم فيلم او يعني اول فيلم هتكلم عنه
اللي هو بيت الروبي بيت الروبي ده
للكريمين كريم عبد العزيز وكريم وكريم
محمود عبد العزيز ده فيلم لايت كوميدي
طبعا كالعاده الكوميدي والاكشن الموسم ده
برده مسيطر على افلام الصيف بست افلام
اولهم بيت الروبي اللي هو هيبقى كل ده
هيطرح في عيد الاضحى
كريم العزيز كان الصيف الماضي وصيف اللي
قبله افلامه حققت اعلى ايرادات في تاريخ
السينما المصريه كيرا والجن السنه اللي
فاتت تحقق حوالي 120 مليون جنيه مصري
والسنه اللي قبلها برده الفيل الازرق فهيا
نقدر نقول الحصان الرابع
الفتره دي
برده اعلن محمد رمضان عن منتج محمد رمضان
اعلن عن تاجيل في المعذره همم وعندنا فيلم
برده رجع امير كراره امير البعبع ايوه
يعني خليني اسالك ايضا يعني بما ان احنا
نتكلم عن السينما الصيفي وراحت السينما
الصيفيه تقلبات الجويه مستمره في مصر ايه
الحكايه
الجو ماله حقيقي يعني يمكن اكتر صيف استمر
مش عارفه انا دلوقتي الدنيا بدات تمطر اهو
وانا بكلمكم وبمنتظر قيام رياح شديده اا
يعني يا ريت اتمنى اني ما اطيرش من هنا
اعلنت امبارح برده حذرت
حضرت هيئه الارصاد من النهارده تقلبات
جويه شديده تصل للزور واليوم
رياح يعني سرعتها توصل ل 50 و60 كم في
الساعه مع احتمال سقوط امطار الرياح دي
محمله بالاتربه نتيجه منخفض جوي قادم من
الصحراء الغربيه طبعا التحذيرات بعد لان
احنا تقريبا من 10 ايام كان حصل رياح
شديده برده
باتربه ادت الى سقوط العديد من اللافتات
الاعلانات في الشوارع والشجر يعني
وقعت عده حوادث فيعني كان لازم
هذه الاستعدادات سمر يعني انت صحيح نسمع
على لبنى ولكن احنا يعني بودنان تنزلي
للارض
شكرا اي والله شكرا جزيلا لسمر باشات من
القاهره يعطيك يعطيك
العافيه لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الاعج
اب الجرس التنبيهات